Fox News senior political analyst pretty
humans us tonight hey Bret that's so
what what do you think the significance
of this indictment yet another
indictment for lying might be well the
first thing that struck me about in
Tucker was that this was a this this man
is accused of a crime that happened
during the course of the investigations
which is to say no investigation no
crime right and this is absolutely
typical of what we have with Special
Counsel and independent counsel
investigations they end up as often as
not being after people for what happened
during the investigation and not so much
for the event or the crime or the issue
for which the investigation was started
in the first place and we're that's
where we are here in this case that's
also true of the Papadopoulos indictment
that's also true and it's also likewise
true that the Paul Manafort and
associated charges or about things that
happen before the campaign which was
supposed to be the principal subject the
events during the campaign the principal
subject the investigation so as you
pointed out earlier Tucker we are pretty
far afield here from the original
apparent purpose of this investigation
which in your if you're right may be a
good thing but but it is also gives you
an idea of just what a wide-ranging and
largely unaccountable force a Special
Counsel investigation can be imagine if
Muller decided in the course of this
investigation to broaden his aim to
uncover the extensive web of foreign
influence on our policy not on our
elections but on how we make laws and
and trade deals etc you know from
spending your life here that is
extensive how I mean that would be an
enormous investigation would it not be
it would be an enormous investigation
I'm not sure what it would find I'm not
sure I quite agree with you about the
extent of that influence it seems to me
just looking back through the the
run-ups that I've seen to our military
interventions and our major policy
changes that they have been widely
debated in most cases and I'm thinking
about the debates I witnessed on the
floor of the house and of the Senate
about these matters and I must say to
you Tucker maybe I'm blind but I'm there
detected dark foreign forces influencing
the representatives and senators that I
saw I saw them arguing the things that
were before the publican and basically
were the were the were the main elements
you'd expect to be indicted being spoken
of in in the course of life may be more
cynical if he did but what will you can
see this that everyone who lives here
knows a ton of people like legitimately
a lot of people who are taking money
from foreign governments to influence
our policy in one way or another that's
not an unusual thing to do for a living
here well it is certainly true that law
firms and lobbying firms that do
business in Washington are often hired
by foreign clients and foreign interests
that's no particular mystery and that
and those that's been as you suggest out
in the open the question I think that it
raises is how and how really influential
are they and I think you know based on
what I've witnessed and I'm not sure
they're terribly influential I might add
to that by the way that speaking of
things that are not terribly influential
if you look at the charges that Muller
has brought in this case to wit
principally the 13 indictments of
Russian individuals that came out last
week and the size of the undertaking
that was described in those indictments
it really doesn't add up to very much
not very much money and not so far as we
can tell very much influence and you
know of course these are 13 individuals
who almost certainly never be prosecuted
they're Russians and and Vladimir Putin
I don't think it will be disposed to
extradite them to the United States to
face Bob Morris charges so there we are
on that there we are on that Brit Hume
great to see you